recevant donc ce soir bernard tellier
ancien négociateur du gign spécialiste
en psychologie comportementale
on va évoquer différents sujets avec lui
mais on va d'abord s'arrêter sur les
faits de violence auxquels sont
confrontés les élus de plus en plus
fréquemment ils sont face à des
administrés agressifs ils s'aperçoivent
que leur écharpe tricolore n'est plus du
tout un frein aux insultes bref ils ont
besoin qu'on les aide à gérer les
conflits devenus quotidiens la
gendarmerie peut le faire elle peut les
aider à la mise en place des formations
flora sauvage a suivi une session il ya
quelques jours c'était dans le
pas-de-calais
reportage jeu de rôle à la gendarmerie
des cuirs dans le pas-de-calais
il s'agit d'une formation contre les
incivilités les agressions vis-à-vis des
élus à faire quelque chose là c'est bon
moi je travaille dans une demi heure
qu'est ce qui se passe sur le problème
c'est qu'on arrive ce matin
l'institutrice nous prévient que la
restauration scolaire et fermé parce que
les dames de la cantine sont en grève
casquette vissée sur la tête et sweat à
capuche le meneur est en fait un
gendarme
monsieur le maire dit non vous n'êtes
pas d'accord avec moi
bon bah voilà mais c'est bon on veut une
solution de celle merde là parce que moi
je vais vraiment m'énerver ça me ceci ça
me ça mais ça m'énerve
le maire tente de désamorcer la
situation je suis comme vous je viens d
problème on a appelé sur mon travail je
finis tout de suite je vous écoute pour
aller le plus vite possible pour essayer
trouver une solution la plus rapide
possible
on va faire le débriefing 1 de ce petit
cas concret est encore là c'est un
exercice donc dans la réalité on peut
rajouter le stress il peut être encore
un peu plus important d'accord donc ce
que la gendarmerie a souhaité faire en
travers cette formation c'est vous
apporter son aide par rapport à ça à la
tête d'un village de 800 habitants
ce maire a déjà été victime de menaces
selon lui cette formation est
indispensable
pourtant je suis chef d'entreprise
depuis des années et des conflits je
sais ce que c'est j'ai vécu voilà des
conflits également dans le monde
l'entreprise
mais là j'ai ce qu'on vit on n'y est pas
préparé d'ailleurs moi j'avais fait une
doléance
c'est à dire que quand on est élu je
pense qu'il ya des formations
obligatoires qu'on devrait suivre et
salle en fait partie comment réagir face
aux agressions aux insultes ou menaces
c'est l'objectif de cette formation de
quatre heures dispensées par les 350
négociateurs de la gendarmerie nationale
donc l'objectif de cette formation c'est
de donner les clés de compréhension aux
élus
pour désamorcer des conflits faciliter
la communication et rétablir la relation
car on constate une augmentation des
violences envers les élus ça peut des
agressions physiques des insultes des
menaces de plus en plus on voit une
augmentation de ce type de fait sur les
réseaux sociaux est aussi dans la sphère
familiale ça c'est vraiment ce qui est
marquant ces derniers temps donc on a
quelques chiffres notamment du ministère
de l'intérieur qui a relevé qu'en 2020
on avait eu un 1276 agression d'élus à
leur agression c'est vraiment tout type
d'agression ce qui correspond à 200 %
d'augmentation par rapport à 2009 donc
effectivement on a une augmentation qui
est vraiment palpable en 2020 ce sont
500 maires qui ont été victimes
d'agressions physiques dans l'exercice
de leurs fonctions et bernard tellier
bienvenu merci d'avoir accepté cette
invitation je le disais vous êtes ancien
négociateur du gign chargé de cours en
psychologie comportementale à
l'université panthéon assas et vous êtes
à la tête d'une société précognition qui
est donc spécialisée dans la négociation
de conflits l'esprit d'équipé la gestion
du stress notamment les élus d'abord
quand on devient maire on n'est pas
spécialement formés à gérer les conflits
des uns et des autres est ce que c'est
un tort on entend ce mr dire ça devrait
être obligatoire une telle formation
vous êtes d'accord avec ça ben disons
qu'avec les temps qui courent hui on a
vu que l'agressivité augmenté dans notre
pays suite à plein de choses à la misère
au confinement etc et donc les gens ont
besoin d'extérioriser roma lettres et
ils ont besoin d'une cible quand vous
avez besoin d'extérioriser votre manette
vous pouvez pas l'être vous pouvez pas
le faire comme ça il vous faut une cible
et les maires sont bien placés pour être
une très très belle cible et comment on
gère et administre et agressif justement
alors j'imagine que ya différentes
situations
mais quels sont les conseils de base
alors déjà il faut savoir
à qui il adresse hinse qui l'agressaient
ce que c'est le maire ou c'est
l'individu est ce que ça peut être un
problème de personnalité perdre quelque
chose de personnel mais ça peut être
quelque chose aussi de professionnels
donc faux de jaf qui sache faire cette
distinction
puis après il faut comprendre aussi que
une colère c'est un symptôme
c'est à dire que prendre vous allez voir
votre médecin et vous avez mal au ventre
et s'il ne fait pas attention à ce
symptôme ça peut dégénérer en grave
maladie la colère au heureusement
qu'elle est la ccco heureusement parce
qu'on va aller là pour nous dire quelque
chose qui ne va pas donc c'est un
symptôme si on ne s'est pas en tenir
compte
ou si on ne la comprend pas cette colère
ce symptôme ça peut dégénérer en
agressions physiques
donc la première chose qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que quand quelqu'un
vous agressent verbalement on parle pas
de l'agression physique et un seulement
de la question verbal quand quelqu'un
vous manque de respect la première chose
qu'il veut c'est qu'on le respecte et
nous qu'est ce qu'on fait on lui donne
tout sauf du respect on lire écouter
monsieur si on continue comme ça vous
n'avez pas me parler comme ça vous vous
changé de ton en vêtements et là
forcément ça dégénère série giner oui et
oui ça dégénère parce qu'on a eu une
mauvaise réaction ni même un mauvais
comportement par rapport à cette
personne c'est normal parce que on se
sent agressé et là forcément je
l'appelais qui est une glaciation
neuronale c'est à dire qu'on n'est plus
capable de réfléchir
et puis on va réagir par instinct
l'instinct animal et ça fait c'est
catastrophique voilà le monde répond pas
de manière agressive mais alors qu'est
ce qu'on fait on n'entend pas l'autre
jour non plus qu'elle est en paix
l'autre une quelle est la première chose
à faire c'est faut comprendre que la
colère est toujours mauvaise conseillère
donc la première chose à faire c'est de
se taire de regarder la personne parce
que la personne qui en colère vous tente
plusieurs pièges trois pièges
déjà elle va essayer de vous faire peur
parce qu'une personne qui en colère fait
peur si vous avez peur vous vous êtes
fait manipuler c'est ce qu'il veut s'il
vous avez pas peur de lui déjà il va
peut-être commencer à changer d'attitude
me va tendre un deuxième piège c'est ici
nous faire basculer en mode colère si
vous basculer en mode colère vous vous
êtes fait manipuler aussi c'est à dire
que si vous avez un ego surdimensionné
lio c'est l'image qu'on aimerait que les
autres et de nous eh ben vous fait
manipuler tout de suite parce que la
façon des ventes de respect vous partez
dans le temps d'une colère et où vous
perdez votre sang froid froid et vous
perdez la face aussi parce qu'un élu n'a
pas perdre
son sang froid donc ça c'est une
deuxième piège et puis le troisième
piège et ça c'est toutes les colères du
monde c'est sous jacent c'est un
conscience et j'ai raison que tu as tort
est là qu est ce que le maire ou qu'est
ce qu'on fait en général c'est une honte
a pas compris c'est moins que les
raisons et c'est toi qui as tort et là
tout de suite ça dégénère parce que si
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec lui vous
êtes un ennemi et si vous êtes un ennemi
va qu'est ce qu'il ya et bien il faut
faut vous adresser
donc il faut à te faire attention à ces
à ces trois pièges ne pas tomber dans
ces trois piège parce que c'est ça amène
et donc montré de la douceur du real
aurait est la première chose à faire
c'est de se taire se taire de le
regarder dans les yeux sans peur pour
passer en manipuler mais sans haine
aussi pour pas augmenter la chose qui
est là là la colère de l'autre et lui
montrer surtout qu'on les écoute ça
c'est important flux donner de l'intérêt
le regarder dans les yeux se pencher
vers lui tourner la tête pour lui
montrer que quand les coups tu n'es
vraiment sincèrement vous comprendre que
cette personne elle a un problème et
l'urgence c'est pas moi parce que si
j'essaie de protéger d'urgence et moi et
dans ce cas là je coupe toute
communication avec lui et là il va le
sentir et qu'est ce qu'il va faire il va
augmenter son agression verbale dans un
premier temps pour me montrer qu'ils en
colère si j'en retiens toujours pas
compter que c'est moi j'essaye de me
protéger
ça va dégénérer donc lui faire
comprendre que ses nuits à la chose la
plus important et c'est ce que vous nous
dit c'est bien valable pour tout le
monde pour finalement toutes les
skieuses on confie pas seulement les
maires n'ont pas les et être humain est
un être humain voilà donc c'est valable
pour tous les êtres humains et après il
ya des choses qui diffèrent un peu mais
on va parler de spécialités de mer ou de
quoi que ce soit c'est par rapport au
caractère de la personne que vous avez
en face de vous mais dans un premier
temps c'est la première chose à des
affaires de se taire de lui donner du
respect 1 c'est dur de donner du respect
à quelqu'un qui nous qui nous en manque
régions froides et tout sang-froid woï
messé labeaume humilité aussi peut-être
mais le truc c'est que enfin en fin de
compte comprendre que c'est cette
personne qui se sent mal
c'est cette personne qui a un problème
et le laisser parler en fin de compte
quand vous avez votre votre sac rempli
d'émotions négatives il faut le vider
eva il va ou services vous êtes tous à
6000 valider toute son émotion négative
sur vous là il faut rien dire il faut le
laisser vider son sac parce que
justement il va passer son mal être
comme ça surtout si vous n'êtes pas visé
personnellement parce que souvent sur ce
sont des mères qui sont visés par ce qu
ils sont représentants de l'état et que
le citoyen est en colère contre le
gouvernement contre tout et n'importe
quoi mais pas du tout contre le maire
personnellement exactement hand c'est un
signe donc une cible c'est pas forcément
on n'avait pas forcément mer c'est ça
qu'il faut que le maire comprennent
aussi c'est c'est un mal être c'est
profond c'est pour ça que nos débuts je
vous ai dit il faut faire attention si
c'est à la personne ou à la fonction et
là il ya une différence là mais si c'est
la fonction oui c'est c'est le laisser
extérioriser sa colère l'écouté et puis
une fois qu'ils arrivent sérieuse toute
sa colère il va se taire en fin de
compte il va se calmer parce que enfin
quelqu'un leur a écouté vous ne l'aurez
pas interrompues a forcément quand
quelqu'un est en colère il faut surtout
pas parler pourquoi parce que si vous
parlez tout ce que vous allez dire ça va
lui servir pour alimenter sa colère
même quelque chose de sympa hein lui
dire monsieur durand venez on va
s'asseoir en rediscuter quoi vous laisse
vous asseoir alors que ça fait une demi
heure que je vous attends est là vous
avez rien compris donc surtout ne rien
dire même quelque chose a pas de ne rien
dire alors là on parle de la colère
d'une personne la colère vraiment
individuelle personnelle il ya aussi une
espèce de colère j'allais dire
collective une colère populaire on
s'aperçoit c'est trois quatre dernières
années qu effectivement beaucoup de
conflit dégénère tourne mal y'a pas une
manif aujourd'hui sans violence on sont
aussi qu'on a
j'allais dire un peuple en colère
comment on négocie avec un peuple en
colère alors c'est beaucoup plus dur
oui forcément parce que vous avez
beaucoup de personnalité je voudrais
simplement revenir sur les verts oui il
ya quelque chose de très important ici
bien sûr à la fin c'est en fin de compte
reconnaître la version de son ministre
et c'est à dire et ça c'est le rassure
minutes ne pas dire que dit d'accord
avec lui mais si vous avez compris ça je
comprends conseiller en colère après moi
et si j'étais à votre place je serais
peut-être encore plus en colère est là
en général ça les calme énormément et
après vous allez seulement montré là
votre version mais reconnaître la
version de l'autre avant de montrer
votre version ne pas chercher à le
convaincre mais chercher à le comprendre
et ça c'est complètement différent dans
la résolution d'un conflit est un point
clé alors la colère de masse la mère de
foule alors la colère de foule
or devises à vide qui dut d'un élu
devant d'une c'est à dire des
manifestations qui tourna mal donc
donc là l'appareil quelle est la cible
c'est le gouvernement c'est des hommes
politiques
on va prendre part entre la crise
sanitaire la première chose à faire et
ça c'est tout préalable absolu à toute
négociation
c'est qu'il faut enfin demande comment
je crois dire ça faut pas chercher à
convaincre les personnes qu'on a la
solution qu'on est les plus forts qu ont
causé des bons médicaments
il faut convaincre les personnes qui
nous entourent de nous faire confiance
c'est vraiment le préalable à toute
négociation
et là par exemple on voit dans cette
crise sanitaire que ça n'a pas été le
cas au début je reprends des exemples 1
la grippe est où le masque c'est pas
obligatoire donc forcément il ya une
perte de confiance perte de confiance et
ce qui se passe eh ben on a trois
cerveaux qui sont imbriqués c'est
cerveau reptilien qui prend le dessus
le serveur est rien comme son nom
l'indiqué d une basique quelques trois
solutions la fuite l'attak ou la
soumission
c'est à dire qu'on n'est plus capable de
réfléchir avec notre néocortex flèche de
l'intelligence et du raisonnement est là
qu est ce qui fait qu est ce qui va se
passer il ya des gens qui vont entrer
dans le déni puisqu'ils ont plus
confiance au gouvernement puisque nous
mêmes il est le gouvernement ne sait
même pas où il va donc ils n'ont plus
confiance
si vous rentrez dans le déni ben vous
rentrez dans un dans une théorie du
complot et on l'a vu serein des terres
17-1 complot ou alors vous passez dans
l'évitement l'évitement c'est quoi c'est
vous allez essayer d'oublier la
situation faire mais c'est votre
angoisse et si vous voulez faire baisser
votre angoisse vous êtes obligés
d'augmenter quelque chose c'est un
communicant pour faire baisser votre
angoisse vous augmentez votre
consommation d'alcool pour oublier ou
alors la consommation de tabac ou alors
il ya des petits malins qui ne vont rien
consommer rien s'injecter consommation
de drogue mais ils vont passer leurs
journées à jouer aux jeux vidéo paraît
c'est une façon d'éviter
la situation alors puisque vous êtes
allé sur le sanitaire je voulais venir
un peu plus tard mais on va y venir
maintenant effectivement depuis quelques
jours on a un gouvernement qui tente de
convaincre les français d'aller se faire
vacciner est la tâche n'est pas simple
leur façon de s'y prendre avec les
français est-elle la bonne je voudrais
qu'on écoute d'abord les mots qu'ils
emploient et le ton qu'ils emploient
regardez la grande différence par
rapport à l'année dernière c'est que les
derniers on disait aux gens restez chez
vous bien que ça aujourd'hui on leur dit
vaccinez vous c'est un plus c'est une
chance extraordinaire le vaccin je le
répète est la carte maîtresse pour cela
l'heure est à la mobilisation générale à
la vaccination massive
que ce soit en se faisant vacciner ou en
convainquant un proche de se faire
vacciner chacun détient une part de la
solution chacun peut prendre part à
l'épreuve d'immunité collective qui nous
attend cet été je ici lancé un appel à
la mobilisation générale pour lutter
contre le risque de nouvelle vague wii
et pour nous vacciner tous bernard
taignons voit qu'il s'y mette tous
qu'ils y mettent de l'énergie de la
conviction parfois même en ton grave des
injonctions forte
est-ce qu'ils s'y prennent bien alors
boris cyrulnik disait corse que la
récitation et mille fois répétés elle
devient la réalité et on voit que va là
ils sont en train de répéter répéter
pour que ça devienne la réalité pour que
ça rentre dans la tête des français et
c'est vrai ça marche un camp
c'est comme ça qu'on apprend d'ailleurs
quelque chose de bien là aussi c'est que
dans une crise il ne faut jamais rester
immobile pourquoi parce que quand vous
restez immobile ses locaux jt c'est là
vous fait des bêtises
donc là au contraire c pure restez chez
vous et là où on va cogiter on va
rentrer dans le déni dans la et cetera
s'était fait quelque chose
allez vous faire vacciner donc c'est une
bonne chose parce qu'il va y avoir un
mouvement et les gens ont un but 1-1 un
but atteint un objectif atteint alors
qu'avant l'objet le confinant c'était
rester chez vous il y avait un rien
atteint donc c'était dramatique
catastrophique
deuxième chose qui est très très bien
aussi c'est qu'il touche l'émotionnel à
la protéger les autres c'est pas pour
vous c'est pour les autres protéger des
autres et donc c'est très très bien de
hal et s'étaler sur ce côté émotionnel
parce que ça va toucher beaucoup plus de
personnes non ils vont sur un côté
rationnel et sera côté émotionnel et on
voit bien que c'est ça fait partie des
caractères différents
quand on étudie la psychologie et déjà
et touche une grosse partie de la
population le discours de la peur ça
peut marcher ou ça peut aussi
désensibiliser ça a marché au mois de
mars de l'année dernière où on a tous eu
très peur les mots étaient effrayants et
on s'est tous confinés on n'a même pas
discuter une seconde là aujourd'hui on
voit quand même que il essaye avec un
discours qui fait peur mais les français
sont peut-être un peu dé sensibiliser
aussi par ce discours de la peur
oui je pense en plus soutenue et
character des français c'est-à-dire
qu'il il leur part entre ils sont dans
un déni de la peur parce que nous on est
français on est comme ça on est plus
fort que les autres et donc je pense pas
que ce soit la bonne solution parce que
encore une fois si on va sur ce côté de
la peur tout ça les gens vont à
l'impression qu'on les manipule et ça
fait complètement l'effet inverse vous
mieux toucher
justement le côté empathique et c'est
pour que les gens puissent voilà
adhèrent et encore une fois le problème
c'est que quand
la première impression
de cette crise a été mauvaise et ça va
être dur de rattraper par la suite monté
et la menace est ce que ça marche il ya
aussi cette menace effectivement qui est
plane au dessus notamment des non
vaccinés où on leur dit c'est soit le
vaccin soit le confinement ça c'est une
bonne technique de négociation de la
menace alors de la menace j'allais dire
non dans l'absolu d'ailleurs pas que
danser la menace c'est pas une bonne une
bonne technique parce que ça fait
souvent l'effet inverse les des gens par
opposition vont vont encore moi se faire
vacciner
c'est très bien dans une dictature et on
voit que ça marche très dans une
dictature mais en france ça ne peut pas
marcher puisque les gens vont contraire
encore une fois je retourne dans ce dans
ce syndrome du déni enfin concernant
engrais psy on appelle ça le coping le
coping c est une c'est un méthode
d'ajustement de son comportement par
rapport à notre environnement
donc si on
on est trop présent si on leur fait peur
tout somme ils vont avoir un copine
inadaptée et l'essentiel c'est d'avoir
un copping adapté j'espère que manuelle
macron vous entend pas ce qu'il est
censé prendre la parole en début de
semaine prochaine peut-être pour
annoncer des mauvaises nouvelles aux
français peut-être des nouvelles
restrictions des obligations c'est un
discours qui va pas plaire beaucoup aux
français quelles seraient les mots qu'il
devrait employer quel serait le ton
qu'il devrait employer selon vous alors
j'ai pas de leçon à donner mais non mais
vous avez une expertise alors oui on est
loin de là je n'oserais jamais faire ça
mais disons que je pense qu'il faut
qu'il aille plus sur le domaine
émotionnel oui on voit que l'émotion
c'est le seul point d'entrée dans
l'inconscient des gens donc aller sur ce
domaine émotionnel je pense que c'est
vraiment la chose qu'il faut faire et
les flatter les français aussi les
encourager et leur dire vous avez déjà
fait d'énormes efforts alors on est fier
de vous mais c'est pas fini
alors les flatter j'aime pas ce mot là
parce que quand on dit flatté ya
manipulation mais oui non mais il ya
toujours un peu de manipulation dans les
discours du manque on parle et adami
passion exactement l'association c'est
de la manipulation mais
il ya deux sortes de manipulations mais
on va pas dire flatté mais je dirais
plutôt reconnaître leurs efforts
brillant reconnaître les efforts de
certains pour la patrie pour moi les
autres c'est à dire c'est de donner
d'énergie assez à ces personnes qui ont
fait des choses pour que les autres se
sentent peut-être un peu gêné ne pas
montrer ce qu'ils ont fait mal mais
féliciter son mais bien et c'est ça qui
peut faire la différence
alors il les soigne on va s'arrêter
quelques secondes sur le cas particulier
des soignants là aussi le gouvernement
ne cesse de les appeler à cela tous se
faire vacciner
mais cette semaine on avait une
soignante qui était l'invité de cette
émission
et quand on lui a parlé vaccination elle
a surtout répondu manque de moyens
promesses non tenues de la part du
gouvernement allait coûter quelques
secondes et et je vous fait réagir après
où ça suffit de nous faire culpabiliser
parce que je rappelle quand même que
c'est ce même gouvernement qui continue
à fermer des lits des services en pleine
pénurie justement en pleine crise
sanitaire
donc pourquoi ça serait nous encore les
responsables de contaminer tout le monde
je vous rappelle que l'année dernière
mine de rien quand l'été asymptomatiques
on nous demande pas notre avis fallait
continuer à les travailler et donc là on
se posait pas la question
et là c'est intéressant parce qu'avec
cette soignante et tout ce qu'elle
représente on a le sentiment que le
gouvernement peut dire ce qu'il veut
leur demander ce qu'il veut il ya une
rupture de confiance
il ya eu une trahison et donc ils ne
veulent pas faire ce qu'on leur demande
encore employer le bon mot la confiance
on revient sur la confiance
alors cette dame ce qu'elle dit sous
jacent c'est que avant fin de compte
elle
on va dire elle vous allez fait acheter
du chantage
voilà vous nous avez promis quelque
chose qu'on ne l'a pas eu
eh ben je ne ferai rien c'est comme si
par endroits de saumon preneurs d'otages
je lui demande un otage et je lui
apporte une voiture ils me libéreront
les otages la porte notre voiture
c'est même pas la peine c'est puis la
peine que j'essaie d'en avoir un
deuxième est donc là ils se sentent
lésés et se sont manipulés et donc ils
rentrent en opposition c'est leur seule
façon de montrer qu'ils ne sont pas
contents ne pas se faire vacciner alors
cette façon de montrer qu'ils ne soient
pas contents on va sortir un tout petit
peu du sanitaire pour terminer cette
interview je voudrais qu'on revienne sur
ce qui s'est passé il ya quelques jours
dans le val d'oise un homme menaçant
armé d'un couteau a été tué par des
agents de sûreté ferroviaire il rôdait
autour d'un groupe d'enfants près de la
gare d'ermont eaubonne il a été visé par
5 tirs atteint par quatre balles deux
agents de la brigade de sûreté
ferroviaire de la sncf sont aujourd'hui
mises en examen pour meurtre
est ce que c'est une situation qui
aurait pu tourner différemment ça fait
toujours tourner différemment il aurait
pu tuer tous les enfants mary donc
voilà alors j'ai vu la vidéo c'est vrai
qu'ils étaient ils étaient armés ils
étaient isolées comme il était menaçant
vous savez que quand on est sur une
crise comme ça qu'est ce qu'on fait est
ce qu on attend qu'un enfant meurt avant
de réagir
ils sont dans une dans une difficulté
ses agents pour réagir ils ont préféré
bâtir et pour épargner la vie des
enfants
cette personne elle était en train de
faire quelque chose de mal donc pour
préserver la vie des enfants ils l'ont
fait après c'est vrai que dans la vidéo
on voit qu'il est qu'il n'est pas si
agressif que ça c'est vrai on le voit
mais quand vous êtes sur le terrain
c'est simple de faire une critique dans
un studio de céder mais qu'on ait
sortira je peux vous assurer que c'est
complètement difficile de faire cette
analyse
c'était peut-être simplement un suicide
by cop 1 c'est à dire que il faisait
tout pour se faire tuer ce ce monsieur
ça se peut mais comment voulez-vous
faire la distinction entre une réelle
agression et une fausse agression quand
vous avez quelqu'un d'armé qui menacent
des enfants c'est très difficile parce
que encore une fois vous êtes sûr mais
rejet par les émotions et le fait que
ces agents soir mais est ce que ça
change la donne le fait d'être armé
c'est à la fois dangereux et dissuasif
c'est ça rend la négociation presque
impossible alors justement le problème
d'une arme c'est que c'est la facilité
donc c'est qu'on a on utilise moins les
mots et on existe peut-être plus les
balles c'est bien pour ça que je vous
pose la question est donc mais je pense
que actuellement en france c'est
important qu'ils soient armés quand même
parce que on ce qu'on voit en ce fait on
se fait agresser de tous côtés il ya
deux semaines il ya deux choses qu'il ne
faut jamais négliger c'est de la santé
et la sécurité et on les gouvernements
successifs ont négligé ces deux choses
là on a retiré des gendarmes des
policiers et qu'est ce qu'on veut c'est
fait on sait faire tout de suite attaqué
par des terroristes
on a baissé notre système de santé pas
de chance et un virus qui arrivait et là
on voit qu'on est vraiment limité
là on reprend conscience de ça et on
augmente tout ça donc ne retirerons pas
les armes ces gens ces agents
ferroviaire rencontre réellement des
difficultés au quotidien ils peuvent
tomber sur un terroriste c'est à eux
d'avoir une formation voilà il faut être
une arme n'est pas dangereuse c'est la
personne qui tient une arme qui est
dangereuse donc il ya une formation une
réelle formation à faire avec ces gens
là vous avez parlé du terrorisme c'est
vrai qu'on est aussi dans un contexte de
menaces terroristes qui rend un peu tout
le monde à crans et y compris ses
agences et policiers ces gendarmes qui
n'ont peut-être plus la force de
négocier mais le problème c'est que on
parle d'une terrorisme low cost se dire
on utilise une arme qui ne coûtent pas
cher pour faire un grand nombre de
victimes à un camion un couteau donc là
dès qu'on voit quelqu'un avec un couteau
forcément on pense à terroristes et la
négociation sait très bien qu'avec le
terrorisme islamiste la théorisation de
la négociation est impossible parce
qu'il se bat pour mourir
comment voulez-vous négocié avec
quelqu'un qui se bat pour mourir c'est
pas possible donc il n'y a plus qu'une
chose à faire c'est de lancer un assaut
et et on l'a vu sur toutes les missions
il s'est même eux qui vont à la soupe
contre les forces de l'ordre en général
les frères kouachi et c'est donc là à
partir de là quand vous voyez quelqu'un
avec un couteau m'a tout de suite vous
pensé au terrorisme vous savez qu'il va
faire un grand nombre de victimes et ben
la formation revient rapidement et la
facilité l'emportent peut-être et merci
beaucoup pour cet éclairage bernard
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à toutes
ses questions très large en différents
thèmes mais au la négociation c'est
vraiment un sujet merci beaucoup m